the paul brothers are doing this
cryptogrift right now and it needs to be
exposed
another one otherwise they just have a
money printing machine i'm sorry to say
and another one and another one and
another one and another one that goes
for all these influencers right they're
just using their fans as personal piggy
banks just reaching in there taking cash
whenever they want it and we have to
talk about it listen i've got to give
you guys a little context before
launching into the new project but let
me say i usually make these
family-friendly uh warning to my
audience this one's kind of necessarily
a little crude
but that will soon become obvious why um
it just kind of is before we get into
that i want to talk to you guys bring
you back to a project that has sort of
been forgotten about by the internet
dink doink this was a project promoted
by logan paul he tweeted about it saying
he's all in this [ __ ] coin while not
disclosing the fact that he actually
created the coin the ceo admitted it in
a statement saying that logan paul
created the entire idea we might as well
you know be be honest about how this
came about logan designed the character
on his phone on snapchat of course the
crypto tanked because it was built on
absolutely nothing and logan quickly
distanced himself from the project but
now jake paul is following in big bro's
footsteps and running his own scheme and
not telling people the whole story
let's uh let's pull up the board here
and talk about it just a couple days ago
jake paul tweeted about a new nft going
on called stick dicks now is that
exactly what it sounds like
yes it's stick figures with
well i think you get the idea now my man
has gone on an absolute shilling spree
he's turned his profile picture into one
of these awful nfts he said just broke
up with my girlfriend because she didn't
mint a stick dicks big dicks energy and
so from his social media post you think
wow he's really excited about this new
nft project is he even affiliated with
it well like his brother it's hard to
tell from his public statements about it
doesn't really appear he's affiliated
just seems like he's excited about this
new project but also like his brother
logan did with ding doing it turns out
that jake is more involved than he lets
on see when you go to the website and
you scroll all the way down all the way
down here jake paul is called an
ambassador for the coin just like logan
paul was an ambassador for dink doing
right when he actually created the
entire idea of dink doink as admitted by
the ceo what up dink doing telegram
it's me logan paul and it looks like
jake has now done the same thing if we
go to the blockchain we find out the
real situation i have here in front of
me the sticks deployer address the one
who created the whole all of the nfts
here right the whole contract
for this and would you like to know who
funded this whole project the biggest
dick of all jake paul
that's right ladies and gentlemen far
from being an ambassador or just like
somebody interested in the project it
turns out the first person to give any
money one ethereum to this deployer
right before it created the whole thing
was
jake paul
and uh do we find that anywhere do we
know that no of course not just like
with logan paul the whole idea is to
just hide how affiliated you are with
these projects you're the creator but
you don't want to be known for that
right because the truth is what does
this actually tell us it's a ridiculous
thing right and this project is getting
nowhere despite his incessant tweeting
about it no one wants these things
obviously quick update guys stick's
twitter account just got hacked and they
just released an allegation against jake
paul that jake paul is receiving 55
percent of the project's profits now
remember this is an allegation but the
person who hacked this twitter account
says stick dick's holders when they
figure out jake was being paid 55
percent of mint for promoting sticks nft
and was on the team behind it now we've
already unveiled that he was on the team
behind it in fact he's the person who
funded the contract but this provides
even more evidence now again this is
just a screenshot we don't know who it's
from but this is in line with what i
would kind of expect jake was getting
paid and the total mint was worth 1.4
million dollars so bear that in mind
that would be worth over 700 000
if this is true
anyways that's the quick update back to
the video but it tells us something very
important about the paul brothers and
just about influencers in general see it
turns out you give these guys millions
of dollars and the most and their whole
job is to create viral things and the
most creative
jake and logan paul can get is creating
dick related
cartoons logan paul's big contribution
to the world has been dink doink and
jake paul has followed it up with
stikdix i think unequivocally proving
what we sort of already know the paul
brothers yes
they will take cash and leave you
holding the bag but at the end of the
day they're just a couple of dicks i
might play you sometimes i'll i'll lead
you down a path
[Music]